[Music]
okay
this idea is called
milo again
what is it milo so milo is a company
that got started back in the day that a
guy who came on the pod jack abraham
started yeah and what milo did was a
very simple thing milo said if you if
you said oh i need to go buy
scotch tape
it would say you would just type it it
was a search engine for finding where
you can go buy a specific product in
person
so you'd be like i want to buy uh you
know
whatever like um
whatever philips razor or something like
that you just type it in and it would be
like it's in stock at this target near
you so he took where you are and then it
knew all the stores inventory
and it just told you if the product's in
stock right there
and like there's
like the world is moving towards
e-commerce yes but
there's still like a very healthy slice
of people that go shop in real stores
and or they want something now today and
they don't want to wait for it to be
delivered in in x amount of time
and so this idea of milo milo got bought
by ebay for like 75 million after like a
couple years
and then it kind of like you know like
many acquisitions just sort of faded
away
and disappeared inside of ebay
but this idea is still a great idea dude
i completely agree man i tried buying
something the other day like some chairs
or something and i had to go to like
eight different like homedepot.com
tractorsupply.com lowes.com walmart.com
even when you go you're seeing the
generic thing you're not seeing like
you're saying like does home depot carry
this okay yeah now let's go to store
locator type in my thing
and then i have to go to each one and do
that and it's like sucks
i needed kids cough medicine and i was
like dude i just need to know do you
have kids robotics or not and then like
usually like
cvs or home depot or wherever they you
type something in and they're like this
isn't near you and it's like oh well
because up here it says my zip code is
like you know eight hours away when i
was on vacation you don't have an easy
way where it's just like searching you
know what i mean uh it takes i
completely agree it takes forever and i
was trying to do this the other day it's
a pain in the back pain in the ass i was
using google shopping but it's not easy
exactly and i know it's also hard to
build right because you have to have
like real-time inventory of physical
stores yeah but that's not that hard if
you go to target and ask for like a
vacuum you they go to target.com and
like type in like that vacuum to figure
out where it is in the store right so
it's in some system so you need to build
like integrations with like the major
backend inventory systems in order to be
able to do this and you have a really
strong reason why they should give you
that access it's like hey dude i'm going
to send you a customer like i'm going to
send you foot traffic to your store like
is there anything a store wants more
than foot traffic to the store i don't
think so so you know like to me milo is
an idea and by the way this just general
thing which is companies that go get
that get acquired and then like kind of
like
dissolve in the big company just go
restart those companies like three years
later yeah i actually think that's a
really fantastic idea that's one of so
that business model i have said that i
hate the advertising business model i
don't entirely hate it but i do hate
that when you're a publisher and you
have to say stuff that you don't really
want to because of an advertiser but and
so i don't love that model but i love
non-publishing business advertising
models because it's the perfect
alignment so basically with milo you
have a site that gets lots of traffic
and then you allow someone to pay money
for a per click or a per view basis and
it's very fair it's the easiest sales
process i think i'm all about that
right uh okay i got some more random
ideas this is what you've got these
these ideas by the way they're a little
bit more like
the the tipsy the drunk ideas the uh so
this might be another drunk idea segment
i might have to take a fake shot here
and we might do drunk ideas because
these are these are you know very very
loose no these are like milo again
that's all right
good bad ideas are
bad ideas but they're the good version
like i'm giving you a good bad idea dude
have you ever asked me did you ever ask
that guy jack uh well he if you could we
could just email him and be like is this
cool
was it would this work again oh no i
didn't ask him yeah we should ask him
we'll see what he says
but also that people should know this
when a founder goes into a space they
can tell you a lot of things about it
but they have so much scar tissue about
that space that they will always tell
you
like
nine times out of ten i should say nine
times out of ten they're gonna tell you
don't do it
because they have trauma
and like you shouldn't necessarily
listen to the don't do it you should
listen to all the reasons why they say
don't do it and then assess are those
still true or do i have a compelling
reason why those are no longer true
um but yeah we should we should ask them
all right so here's my here's drunk idea
number two
all right you're um
you take zoom calls right yeah
get a pulse yeah
what's the experience like okay let's
say you had a meeting with me before the
era of zoom we were meeting in person
you come to my office for a meeting
what's that experience like while you're
waiting for that meeting in just another
three minutes before the meeting what do
you get
so lately nothing but i recently did
something where they had an ad on zoom
and i thought that was intriguing no no
in real life what do you get what's the
best version of a real life
before your meeting you show up at the
building you've done this water yeah
water famous new york bougie places
you've been there what
someone attractive greet you they ask
you if you need anything to drink they
give you the drink that you have a seat
you look around they got art everywhere
you start to feel like wow this
company's pretty cool huh like yeah oh
look at that they got that wall over
there with all the like cool you know
little handbooks
yeah you know like i went to one the
other day like the bathroom sign oh by
the way there's another drunk idea
this is coming next coming next drunk
idea the bathroom sign of this thing was
uh it didn't say men it said batman and
they had like a cape on the guy a little
bit
and i was like ah these guys they like
to have a good time these guys got a
great sense of humor so i got all this
all this information all this persuasion
before i even went into the meeting
which where which office is this
i can't say but we um but zoom needs
this
zoom needs a waiting room experience
this is a feature for some product
manager at zoom we need a dope waiting
room experience or even even it can be
built off zoom right there's like
whatever a trillion zoom calls a day
give me a dope waiting room where i can
send somebody that's connected to the
zoom call and then when they're ready
they can come in but before that they
get a branded
they get a branded experience a virtual
office a virtual vibe of who they're
dealing with what that person's all
about
and uh create a little a little website
a little website space for them to uh to
hang out have some fun have a drink
enjoy themselves i did this call with a
company
i forget what they're making maybe
they're making a game and i logged in
and i was like a little bit early and
they had like a teaser video like a one
minute long teaser video and because
they were the host of the zoom it
automatically played and so when i got
to have the meeting i was like pretty
psyched up yeah i was psyched up it was
awesome it was really cool and it almost
felt like they were like by it
i was like is this what is this new
feature is this was that an ad that you
paid zoom to play and they're like no
they have this new feature where they
allow you to show like an amp up like a
video prior to the meeting starting and
it was really cool but dude how about
the fact that zoom has been we've been
in a pandemic for three or two years and
it's like the same [__] over and over
and over again yeah
no features and the stock cut in half
what's going on
yeah
this is not good i'm more mad about one
of those than the other i'll let them
figure out which one is actually
bothering me and there's so many people
that go to that uh landing page where it
says like click here to open up zoom and
it's just a blank
yeah it's a blank page there's so much
real estate there i get there when i've
already clicked a zoom link guess what i
do want to open zoom you didn't have to
re-ask
on similar web zoom.com gets 1.7 billion
visits a month and it's the 26th most
popular website in the world and that
page is just this blank page i cannot
believe that they can make maybe
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
just in like an ad
yeah just like the new batman movie
needs to play like a 15 second trailer
to everybody today like that's what
that's what needs to happen for real i
do think that that's like with so much
wasted space
yeah i'm i'm more in the meeting room
the waiting room bucket i want to you to
be able to like say something about who
you are by showing what you know you can
decorate it you can put your little
drinks there a little interactive thing
you can play jenga you can do whatever
you want right like make it make it cool
all right so that's one idea the second
one is what i teased a second ago it's
called
i don't have a personality give me one
or i'm not funny make me funny it's a
it's a store like spencer's back in the
day remember spencer's or whatever i
just went to a hot topic i just went to
one the other day
yeah it's awesome
all right
that's the actual joke for for me and
sarah we had like a date night on friday
and we're like you want to go walk
around the mall and go to the food court
so we did and it wasn't
date night that's awesome it was awesome
man it was so much fun so spencer's is
still a thing yes and hot topic we went
to both of them
and this shirt that i've got that i'm
wearing i bought it from abercrombie
dude abercrombie's cool right now
i believe you i believe you
so my idea is it's the b2b version of
spencer's so it's just [__] for you to
put around the office
that's gonna make your office more fun
and interesting i think we should
workshop that name a little bit though
what was your name
i don't have a personality please give
me one yeah
maybe there's an acronym in there
yeah like we want like it needs to be a
word that's like botox but it's for
injecting personality into your company
instead of like filler into your like
lips so so basically what this is botox
for your company what it's going to do
is it takes all the common items of a
office of any office so bathroom door
plaque you know the bathroom door signs
the exit sign the emergency exit sign
meeting room things little chash keys on
the table for meetings um you know like
your welcome desk sign in mat and and
and like little bell you know like it's
just all items like that
and then
it'll make you seem like the fun
interesting version of your company
because we just have the we take the
comment and we do it uncommonly
we just have this exit sign do you
remember this we had this exit sign at
the dojo where over the exit side
someone wrote ipo
because that was that was like
that was the goal the goal exit was an
ipo so we had an ipo sign instead of an
exit sign
uh it was pretty awesome but uh
i completely agree yeah like this toilet
paper opportunity
opportunity in that toilet paper roll
there's an opportunity in the bathroom
mirrors there's opportunity everywhere
in your office to demonstrate a little
personality one time when i went to
vaynermedia they had vayner branded
bottles of water it was awesome and i
still remember it and it stuck out have
you been to a company that has a head of
their own branded bottles it just
no but i also i don't feel like i would
have thought that was awesome why did
you think that was so awesome was the
label like just looking amazing or
something i just it was weird i thought
it was cool it was quirky it stood out
it was just a bot i mean it was just a
normal cheap costco bottle of water and
somehow some company they probably paid
a quarter per bottle and they just wrap
it just had their label on it i thought
it was a neat i remember when i went to
twitch for the first time when we were
trying to sell the company and they were
like you want anything to drink you know
here's the little fridge and i opened up
there was a it was my first time ever
seeing boxed water and so i was like
boxed water fun i thought it was like
their gimmick and i was like that's cool
i picked it up
you ever drank boxed water
tastes nasty by the way doesn't taste
good
tastes disgusting and also you're
drinking from the old school like milk
carton yeah it's like drinking orange
juice it's like drinking orange juice
out of like a thermo like a metal
thermos it just doesn't taste good it
doesn't doesn't taste right and then it
doesn't even look right or feel right so
now i'm in this meeting trying to sell
my company biggest day of my life and
i'm like a toddler drinking from this
like carton of water and like the thing
was just getting all wet and
disintegrating and i was like oh god do
you have a do you like a dumpster i can
go throw this away in because it doesn't
trash me
it's like a paper straw
all right here's my next drunk idea
um
shawn's like [__] [__] them turtles
i don't want to choke myself to save the
turtles that's what was happening
i have moved straight to the end
so the the next one is
i don't know what i need to call this i
need a catchy name i'm going to call it
um
discord property managers because i
can't think of a name okay so basically
there's a ton of discords out there now
basically this is like
community managers is a job title right
a lot of people have communities
communities are all the rage now
and there's a ton of discords especially
in the crypto worlds ton of discords
they're so hard to figure out that are
just like noisy there's spammers and
scammers and then there's new people
coming in they never use discord they
never use crypto this is like confusion
all around
i think somebody should build the best
property management company for your
discords just be like dude we are the
best at managing discords and we will
manage your discord for this flat fee
and just build a brand
around being an amazing property manager
for your digital property for your
digital spaces that's a great idea
so vaynermedia
we'll talk about that again when they
started their whole thing was like
social media is new we're like the guys
you know we know how to handle it and
basically most of their job titles were
called community managers or early on a
popular job title at their company was a
community manager we basically just met
will comment on everyone's comment uh
you know if you're
uh
oreos and someone like makes a comment
on about oreos we just reply and i
actually think that
and they got big that way i bet you
vaynermedia makes 200 plus million in
revenue it's a big-ass company and you
do the exact same thing but now the new
community or the new social is community
and i think that you've got
you know david spanks yeah of course
it was way early he was just early dude
he just if he started that like two
years ago instead of seven years ago
that would be like a hundred million
dollar company right now and uh he was
just a little too early he was early
make it all the way so david spanx had
this company called cmx summit it
originally was a conference for
community managers then it was like an
online community and everything and he
sold it i don't even remember who bev
the big idea was like you have a you
have a ceo then you have a cto they
handle they are in charge of the
technical part of things you have a
cio they're the chief information
officer cso cmo for marketing so you
have all these c-suites and that his
belief was that community is going to be
a big part of companies and so you're
going to have
a cxl i think was the thing they were
going for which is like a
a chief community officer or some [__]
like that i don't know why i was x cmx i
don't know what they were trying to do
but like basically it was
this is going to be a job title at the
c-suite level and then you're going to
have then like a senior community
manager and then like a junior community
manager like this is a whole new job
function and he was right i don't know
how to do it and he was totally right
and totally early which is the same
thing as being totally wrong and that's
what sucks
yeah he was totally right and totally uh
early i i completely agree uh he was on
that like it felt like 10 years ago
yeah but i think this is a good idea
it would be a pain in the butt to run an
agency but i think this is an agency
that could crush
let me give you uh okay can i give you
two ideas so there's a guy i'm gonna
these are these are 100 stolen from
another podcast i heard so i listen to
bill simmons podcast sports podcast and
bill has his buddy kevin wild or wilds
something like that he comes on
and he does half-baked ideas
and he is he is like we need to get him
on this pod because his half-baked ideas
are like
he does drunk ideas and he's been doing
this for years and it's just a running
bit
he only comes on like twice a year but
when he does he's got these amazing ones
so can i give you yeah the two most
recent ones he did and he's by the way
he's amazing at pitching them he's even
better than me at pitching these these
drunk ideas all right so
first one is called
fit furniture
okay fit furniture you might be
wondering what is what is fit furniture
i've been hearing a lot about it lately
do we make
the highest quality furniture no we do
not
do we have the best prices
sure don't
do we have furniture that fits through
doorways you bet your ass we do because
moving furniture is a requirement of
furniture and all furniture is built as
if everybody's home has just open walls
that you could just drag these things
through so fit furniture is furniture
optimized to fit through the standard
doorway width
you know do you know uh lovesack you
remember lovesack
yeah of course so they're huge bean bags
right yeah but their new shtick is
furniture that fits through a door it's
modular
it's a it's a couch that you take apart
and i i try so at my airbnb the way it
works these guys are idiots they put a
spiral staircase going up and you on the
second floor and that's the only stairs
and you can't carry anything up a spiral
stairs so i was like i can't get a couch
unless i could take it apart uh and
there's this company in texas and
they're the couch guys and they take
apart your couch just for this problem
they take the whole thing apart and they
rebuild it wherever you want it and i
was like all right well i can't do that
so i looked at i i looked at luck
because it's an airbnb i don't want a
fancy couch i looked at lovesack they're
interesting but it's like three grand
for one of their couches or four grand
for one of their couches so i ended up
going with a futon because i could build
a futon upstairs but uh
dude it was such a pain finding a couch
that could fit into certain doorways
that wasn't like over five thousand
dollars i completely agree if you want
to pay five star prices for that college
experience sam's short-term rental
scotch cupboard sleep on a futon
stars no we don't call it a futon
because if we call it a pull-out couch
because it's like crazy comfortable it's
basically like a mattress that you can
sit on sometimes but uh
yeah i didn't i was embarrassed to call
people i was embarrassed to call it a
futon that's for sure that was your
nickname in college right
let me give you a second idea his second
idea is called bulletin board material
so this is for this for i think this is
for you i think you are the target
market for this so it's for somebody
somebody who you got a little chip on
your shoulder and you like it
it's if that ship on your shoulder has
made you who you are today there would
be no hustle if there weren't any
doubters dude they say they're skeptics
chips on shoulders create chips and
pockets
exactly
but what happens if you you grew up
around nice people you don't have a chip
on your shoulder or maybe you had that
chip
you sold the hustle and now everybody
tells you you're so great you don't know
you were so unlucky that you had a
healthy father and a yeah
mother who treated you well like you
know like [__] me right
you could do anything that's such a
disadvantage because i grew up in an
emotional emotionally healthy household
the biggest disadvantage there is the
biggest with money
we help solve that problem we are for
the healthy middle class family who has
lost their edge
and what brother morgan material is
is it is haters as a service and so what
we do is
we go and find
the people oh
my first people we love the podcast
every day people love the podcast but
guess what in some corners of the
internet there's people who hate this
podcast and so what haters as a service
does is it compiles that information and
it takes out the real toxic stuff that's
gonna you know give you nightmares at
night so there's some filtering
and it just
drips to you a little motivation every
week that just reminds you that some
people believe you can't do it that some
people say you're not so prepared for
this podcast some people say sean your
camera's not working and you you know
you got to get that sorted and so it
just gives you that healthy dose of
haterade it's like
your best and we just hire a bunch of
immigrant mothers who children are grown
and they have some free time and they're
like well you know your brother's a
doctor sean
you know exactly i actually know two
women who could run the service
single-handedly
i'm not gonna name any names
they can serve thousands of customers
you know it's not too late to go back to
school
[Laughter]
yeah so haters as a service uh what do
you think of that idea yeah yeah
yeah i'm down we'll just call it like it
has it just you're just naked people all
day
yeah exactly uh and it's immigrant
mom.com yeah
yeah live like an immigrant
yeah there's a reason why immigrants are
always the best
immigrantmentality.com um all right yeah
those are those are my drunk ideas you
gotta do drug ideas i feel like um i'm
not creative like you all my ideas are
just like legitimate money-making ideas
you know
[Laughter]
it's hard for me to come up with bad
ideas
how do you do it yeah i'm like the lady
gaga of ideas there are no deep hits or
there's no deep tracks hits only
all right that's it that's the episode
[Music]
you